[Music]
hey everyone welcome to their
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video we'll be discussing Severus
Snape his ability to fly exploring the
question was he a vampire we don't see
or hear about vampires too much in the
Harry Potter story and the following
blurb from Pottermore gives us a brief
introduction to the topic although
vampires exist in the world of Harry
Potter as shown by the literature that
Harry and his friends study and defense
against the dark arts they play no
meaningful part in the story the vampire
myth is so rich and has been exploited
so many times in literature and on film
that I felt that there was little I
could add to the tradition in any case
vampires are a tradition of Eastern
Europe and in general I tried to draw
from British mythology and folklore
when creating adversaries for Harry
aside from passing mentions therefore
the only vampire whom Harry meets in the
books is sanguine II in half-blood
Prince who makes a faintly comic
appearance at a party but I'm not
completely buying this here's why I
think that Severus Snape makes the
perfect vampire and why I think that his
character possesses many of the defining
characteristics of the vampire a vampire
is defined as a creature from folklore
that is subsists by feeding on the vital
essence generally in the form of blood
of the living but there's more to a
vampire than drinking blood in order to
survive let's look at some of the
defining characteristics of a vampire
and how they relate to Snape the first
major characteristic of a vampire that I
want to touch on is avoiding sunlight
it's well known that vampires like some
animals avoid light they have a tendency
to inhabit dark conditions and some
spend their lives in permanent darkness
this describes Snape quite well
Snape's office in the dungeons of
Hogwarts is described as follows the
office was a gloomy and dimly lit room
found in school dungeons the shadowy
walls were lined with shelves of large
glass jars filled with slimy revolting
things such as bits of animals and
plants floating in potions of varying
colors
Snape's office is perhaps the darkest
and airiest of all of the officers
belonging to Hogwarts staff and the
dimly lit gloomy room in the dungeons of
the school seems like the perfect place
for one type of creature
a vampire and yes we have seen Severus
Snape in direct sunlight on occasion but
he might have figured out a way to spend
time in sunlight as we know that he is
an incredibly talented wizard and
excellent potion ear next up we have
heightened senses vampires are said to
have heightened vision hearing and sense
of smell though I don't have too many
specific examples of Snape exhibiting
super heightened senses he does seem to
have a bit of a habit of making an
appearance whenever students are
breaking rules wandering out of their
common rooms when they shouldn't be or
methylene in matters that do not relate
to them sure he's always lurking around
the castle at night but he also seems to
be particularly aware of what's
happening at the castle at all times if
you can record the night that Harry
wandered into the restricted section of
the library with his invisibility cloak
you'll remember that he bumped into
Snape and Quirrell even though Harry was
under the invisibility cloak an
extremely advanced magical artifact the
Snape still had a strong intuition that
someone was there this was shown by him
reaching into the air I think that this
is a reflection of his perhaps
heightened senses next up we have
morphing or in the Harry Potter world
transfiguration vampires are said to
have the ability to morph into another
form like a bat often behind the Shroud
of a cloak after morphing they disappear
creating the illusion that they have
vanished flying away from their
aggressor on one occasion Snape does
exactly this in the Deathly Hallows we
see Snape jump from the tower of the
Hogwarts castle the following passage
depicts Snape flying in front of
mechanical Harry and some of the
students he jumped said Professor
McGonagall you mean he's dead Harry
sprinted to the window no he's not dead
said McGonagall what this passage
suggests is that Snape flew away JK
Rowling is reported to have stated that
all Wizards have the power of flight
innately but the vast vast majority need
a broom to achieve it in Voldemort case
he was so focused and powerful that he
was able to channel the power to fly
unsupported harnessing the energy
through himself rather than through a
broom
maybe Snape did the same but I really
think that he achieved it in another way
going back to the first passage where
Snape jumps from the Hogwarts Tower
there's one line that really piqued my
interest I think that it could shed some
light on his method of flying Harry saw
a huge
like shape flying to the darkness as far
as the books are concerned when multiple
uses unsupported flight he maintains his
original form so what's this bat like
shape
why would sniper resemble a bat my
answer his name's a vampire if you
aren't sold on that theory
then another explanation for the bat
like shape could be that he was a an
animagus or be used transfiguration to
turn his arms into wings Snape was a
gifted wizard and he was once the
student of Horace Slughorn who was known
to be talented at Transfiguration this
would not have been out of the question
for him to achieve and last of all just
look at Snape now let's compare him to a
couple of vampires not sold yet
fair enough this is just an idea what do
you guys think was Snape a vampire an
unregistered animagus a talented
practitioner of transfiguration or an
expert at unsupported flight let me know
down in the comment section below until
next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]